hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're
continuing our coverage of the 2018
World Chess Championships being held in
London England between the champion
Magnus Carlsen and the concent there
Fabiano Caruana
the first I games they have all been
drawls which brings us to this historic
game because if they do draw this game
it would be the first time in world
chess championship history the first
nine games end up being a draw Magnus
Carlsen wants to make sure that does not
happen he's playing the white pieces and
he only has two white pieces two more
times in game number nine here in game
number 11 wants to take advantage of
that but in the back of his mind he has
to know that if they are tied after
twelve games it is gonna go to blitz and
rapid chess and in the last 11 years
Magnus Carlsen is undefeated has won all
nine playoffs in a major tournament that
he's played in he's just the best out
there when it comes to fast chess so
that is something that he has his
advantage although any times he's been
asked about that he said you know I want
to focus on this classical style right
here especially in this game since he
has the white piece so we'll go ahead
and get started
he starts with pawn to a c4 he's tried a
few variations in his opening repertoire
in this tournament pawn to c4 or
something he started out in game number
four pawn to e5 sort of the reverse
Sicilian plays very different than the
Sicilian as we talked about in game
number four Knight to c3 Knight f6 we
get into the four Knights game and then
pawn to g3 so this gets into the English
opening in fact the first eight moves
are exactly the same from game number
four most of these players as they come
into their preparation there's two or
three openings that they really want to
play and then within those openings they
have spent countless days and hours
months even especially their teams that
they're training with studying different
variations of those openings and they
try to see how their opponents are going
to adapt sometimes they may play a game
with the sole intention of figuring out
how is my opponent going to play this
and then I plan on actually using my
main preparation a couple games late
down the road since I know how they're
going to play so after the first eight
moves are the same we see magnus carlsen
play Bishop to g5 now in game number
four he played Bishop to d2 not very
aggressive move magnus carlsen really
hasn't been that aggressive all
tournament like every interview we've
seen for Magnus Carlsen all we hear is
him say yeah I didn't play my best chess
I felt like I was defending every game
we analyzed Fabiana was on the attack of
that matter Fabiano has the white or the
black piece is always putting pressure
on Magnus Carlsen so in this position
was nice to see Magnus Carlsen not going
for a development move but not very
aggressive and do that he that's exactly
what does he plays an aggressive move of
bishop here to g5 now in this position
is very important that Fabiano responds
correctly while he may eventually want
to play something like pawn to f6 he has
to be aware of the threats that manage
Carlson has this starts to open up a
weakness on this light square diagonal
Queen to b3 is a very serious threat
this is pinning down the Knights right
here and if we start to look at some
different options one would be if you
say I'll just go ahead and capture this
bishop right here Knight to g5 is a very
deadly move this opens up this light
square bishop on g2 to take the knight
up here that would be checked yes you
are giving up material but your
opponent's the King side here for black
is not secure and if your opponent is
just gobbling up material in the center
of the board
that's not where Fabiana wants to be
that would be a very good attack for
Magnus Carlsen if instead black decides
to play something like Knight to be for
this does defend the square here on d5
you could display Queen up here to c3
attacking the bishop if we see the pawn
take we could have the Queen take here
and you can see weekend King side for
black double pawns on the G file Magnus
Carlsen should have a good game from
here so first after Bishop to g5 we see
Fabiana correctly take the knight here
on a c3 after the pawn recaptures
then and only then do we see the pond
come here to f6 bishops gonna retreat
back to c1 I I still felt like Magnus
Carlsen should have brought his queen
out here to b3 this check so he is you
know gaining a tempo doesn't have to
worry about his bishop falling right
here
we may see King to h8 now the bishop can
come back to e3 still more central in
the game than coming back here to see
one if like wants to take that's fine
man is Carlson has all the pawns in the
sinners can be interesting to see how he
would continue here but the the Queen's
attacking the pawn maybe if Fabiana once
gives LightSquared Bishop involved he
plays rook to b8 I thought like Magnus
Carlsen would do fine here he decides to
retreat his bishop back here to see one
instead Bishop e6 just development move
getting more material involved and then
he swings it over here to be - so the
reason it came back to c1 didn't want to
bring it here to be - i just prefer
getting the Queen involved into the game
Bishop comes back here to b6
pawn to a d4 Bishop d5 sinner Queen up
here to see - pawn takes and the pawn
recapture so both sides I'd say are
looking pretty good Fabiano I really
like his position he has both of the
bishops eyeing down on the King side the
board from Magnus Carlsen so for that I
would say those that's a good setup all
this pieces are working well together
what matters Carlson has going for him
is he has the two central pawns he is
controlling a lot of the action in the
center and so for that I would say he
has a very very slight advantage but I
don't think either player right now has
a huge advantage over the other the
bishop comes down here to e4 attacking
the Queen Queen comes up to a b3 check
Bishop back here to a d5 now Queen to d1
and this is where things get pretty
interesting from many moves ago we can
clearly see that once this pawn came to
f6 the light square diagonal was going
to be a weakness for Fabiano
and magnus carlsen has his queen here
that he can easily attack this agonal
but he would really like to get his
LightSquared bishop involved into the
action
much like Fabiano has both of his
bishops involved this is blocked off by
the knights right here and there hasn't
been a strong you know move that magnus
carlsen can move with this night and
then Fabiano makes a big mistake he
takes with his bishop here on f3 what
that allows is magnus carlsen to come up
here to b3 check and then he's gonna be
able to get his bishop involved into the
game so King to h8 the bishop takes here
on f3 and it gets it activated so yes it
was an exchange but now Magnus Carlsen
has the bishop pair and he gets the
piece that he wanted to get developed
into the game Fabiana I don't think got
much out of that exchange the knight
comes takes here on d4 so goes up
material but it's still exposing this
pawn here on b7 so magnus carlsen will
be able to get that material back Bishop
takes here on d4 and then the Queen
comes down and takes on d4 always
important to think about how you're
going to take with your material Queen
to d4 is so much better than Bishop to
d4 why is that because the rook can
swing over here to d1
and black is going to lose material the
bishop cannot move here or the Queen is
going to fall if you want to try to hold
on to this you know really you may want
to have something like Queen to b6 but
if you try pawn to c5 holding on to this
material then pawn to e3 material is
going to fall you can move your Queen to
save it your bishops gonna just fall
from this Bishop so definitely want to
make sure that you capture correctly in
your own games that's a Fabiana does he
takes with this Queen down here on d4
now we are just over 18 moves in the
game so far Magnus Carlsen has always
spent a more than a minute on two of his
moves and none of his moves have gone
past 90 seconds so you can tell that he
is extremely prepared it almost things
like of the nine games they've played so
far this is the one where we're kind of
watching and saying like oh wow
Magnus Carlsen has a very good
preparation for this opening he has some
specific lines he wants to go down
putting his opponent into some tough
spots and he's actually winning the time
control he's about 40 minute lead
advantage over Fabiano at this spot
really every other game he's been behind
trailing Fabiano in that respect just
feels like Fabiano has been more
prepared up into this point Oh Magnus
Carlsen over the next few moves does
start to spend some time to figure out
how he wants to attack but did like the
fact that he came prepared for this
opening knew every move that he was
really gonna make didn't spend too much
time thinking about it so the from here
pawn to e3 attacking the Queen also just
solidifying at the pawn chain a little
bit Queen to e5 the bishop does take
here on b7 so both sides are now equal
in material rook swings to d8 always
want to get your rooks involved into the
center of the board rook over here to d1
just counter-attacking that queen up
here to e7 and then pawn to h4 and this
is where a lot of discussion during the
game a lot of commentary if you were
watching the super computers analyzing
the game this was a spots where Magnus
Carlsen had a big advantage you can
count up material and say that it's
completely even but these super cute are
thinking way beyond just which you can
see right here and they thought Magnus
Carlsen had a much more aggressive
position that his pieces could do a lot
more damage in the endgame but they did
not like pawn to h4 they wanted Magnus
Carlsen to get his bishop more involved
into the game had a lot of different
option as far as how he did that but
kept it back here on b7 decided to push
up here on h4 pawn to g6 the man is
crossing continue down that game playing
pawn to h5 pawn recaptures here on h5
yes this does weaken the King side a
little bit more but it was already
fairly weak I don't think you have to do
this but then he plays Queen to c4
Bishop to f5 and then Bishop down here
to f3 attacking the pawn here I don't
even think he necessarily
needs to do this I think he could have
been more aggressive start to attack
other pieces Bishop here to c6 make
sense to me attacking the rook the
double pawns on the H file you don't
have to worry about it your opponent's
gonna have a tough time defending this
material especially the pawn here on h5
he doesn't have a LightSquared bishop
you do have the LightSquared Bishop you
can get this material at any time this
starts to really put your opponent to
the test we're just playing Bishop down
here to f3 I just don't think he had to
do it in this position pawn to h4 says
yes I'm already fine in material I know
this piece is going to come off the
board I might as well give my opponent a
worse position first we see a rook
exchange and then pawn to h4 now this is
a serious threat if I could choose one
side that I would like I'm choosing
Fabiano's because the threat of Queen
coming down here to h4 is a real thing
you can also close off the door with
pawn to f4 the Queen right here that
Magnus Carlsen has is defending this
pawn but I think this King here on G 1
is even more exposed than Fabiano's
Queen here on h8 now black brings his
rook over here to GA to check it King to
h1 and then Queen down to f6 this pawn
still defended by the Queen but just
centralizing this Queen a little bit
more still has the threat coming down
here to h4 white has to be worried about
that Queen over here to f4 needs to make
sure that he is still defending
correctly and then Bishop to c5 and this
is an interesting spot and I really like
this move from Fabiano because it sets a
trap that a lot of players may fall into
now Manas Carlsen not one of those
players but if you just look at this
position you could easily look at this
and think that the Queen could take here
on c7 because if you say yeah I'm gonna
take a pond you're gonna take a pawn
here on h4 but then I'm just gonna swing
my Queen down here to h2 I'm completely
safe I'm not too worried my pawn here is
on a light square yeah there's no
additional threat here and if this was
that the
case if the queen game came down here to
h4 you'd be right this is an even
position you know I still don't like the
fact there's no pawns in front of Magnus
Carlsen but that's not the real threat
in the game the real threat is after the
Queen takes here on c7 Bishop to d6
because this is stopping the Queen from
defending the King side of the board and
that's really the the biggest threat
that Black has going on right now so you
know how could white continue to try to
hold on to this if he try something like
Queen to c4 needs to hold on to this
material right here
well now pawn to f4 this is stopping the
the Queen from doing anything maybe the
bishop comes back here to g2 Queen down
h4 check King to g1 rook takes
sacrificing King takes pawn to f3 this
is the discovered attack and now the
Queen is going to fall so that's not
gonna work at all it's all a really bad
place for white to be and if he doesn't
bring his queen down the Queen's just
gonna come down to h4 and take that
right away so Magnus Carlsen does not
fall for this after the bishop here to a
c5 he plays rook to d1 says let's go
ahead and exchange if you want to that's
exactly what happens in the game and
then Bishop to d6 so it's hacking the
Queen that's fine brings the Queen over
here to a4 still defending this square
here on h4 now pawn to f4 Queen up here
to a7 says yeah don't mind if you take
right here I'm gonna just recapture with
my queen
so Magnus Carlsen does have a pawn
advantage but comes back takes it here
and then we get into the in game in this
position it does look like it's fairly
even for both sides no longer is there
one side that has an opportunity really
you can't really set as many traps as
you could before but pawn to a4 just
pushing on the Queen sides and nothing's
going over there
Bishop down here to d1 we do see the
exchange in the stern of the board and
then opposite colored bishops so it is
important that you see this past
right here it does end up on a light
square bishop so that is a bonus that
madness Carlson has because his opponent
has a dark square bishop but there's
also no real way to stop the star square
bishop from the you know the square here
on a seven he can just defend this
entire diagonal and there's not much
madness Carlson can do so they play pawn
a five and then both sides get their
kings involved into the game and it's
not even one of those things where if
Magnus Carlsen could get his King over
here to the Queen side faster he would
necessarily win it's still gonna be
difficult for him to worry about this
bishop right here he can never bring his
king to a7 as soon as the pond comes up
here madness Carlsen would have to deal
with the bishop coming sacrificing and
pushing his pawn all the way on the
h-file Fabiana would end up winning that
but King here to g2 you do want to get
your King involved into the game pawn to
f4 bishop here to b6 you start to see
the pawn pushing forward on the King
side Bishop up here g4 and then both
sides just maneuver to see if anybody is
gonna make a mistake but you can see
here there's just nothing going on from
both sides so yeah I'll go ahead and you
know take this pawn if you want to take
the other one we do see the King come to
c6 it doesn't matter if he takes it
though you say yes this is open sure
yeah I'm gonna take your pawn here on f4
check the King moves great bishop down
here to e3 and I'm gonna stop there's
nothing that magnus carlsen can do to
stop as soon as this palm pushes he can
just sacrifice it and Magnus Carlsen
can't win with just a bishop and he has
the only pawn left on the board so it
doesn't really matter how Manesar Magnus
Carlsen continues he decides to play
King to c6 but a few moves more they're
just moving around here after 56 moves
they decide to go ahead and draw so we
have set the record we have 9 draws in a
row to start the world championship
I felt like Magnus Carlsen was more
prepared afterwards he just seemed so
bummed that he gave up an opportunity it
almost seemed like this was the the one
game
he felt like he was actually gonna win
his preparation had paid off and he said
he just didn't play well towards the
middle and the end of the game was not
able to turn that into a victory and he
said he just needs to play better he's
not thinking about tiebreakers at all
just said he needs to execute Fabiano on
the other hand this is really the first
time that he's escaped what should have
been a victory for Magnus Carlsen he was
pretty happy for his drawl and he's
gonna have the white pieces two more
times in game 10 and the final game in
game 12 if it does get to that point so
all-in-all an exciting game although it
did in in a draw so tomorrow we will
have game number 10 for those in the
United States celebrating Thanksgiving
happy Thanksgiving to everyone and we
will see you tomorrow for Thanksgiving
some chess chess does not stop even for
the holidays so we will definitely be
having commentary tomorrow so be
watching for that but thank you guys so
much for watching this video and I will
see you guys tomorrow